thank you usa stopping
general's side helping small crossover
stopping the wrong height
[Music]
hello squire and welcome to she doesn't
read the news with me
chris turner squire yes what's quite
like a night squire
oh good day sir thank you for visiting
me humble podcast
what is what are you referring to with
squad for the person listening
is that a thing it's a gender neutral
term i'm sorry i have decided
i recognize you were probably trying to
sort of sound cool i was trying to start
the podcast i was trying to
provide some some alternative beginning
you know we we've done some bonjours
we've done some
oh hello you laughed when i did that one
that was maybe episode three
we're on episode six now but for anyone
listening new who
who are you i'm your wife alice nguyen
my wife alice win not for much longer
maybe it's the divorce episode
welcome to the divorce episode you can't
divorce me yet
when can you divorce me without losing
your agreement so i can apply for my
final green card in july
my kind of unconditional so in america
for those who don't know to get
residents you have to have a green card
and you can obtain that
by marrying an american but you have to
then prove that you've
been in a real marriage for i think
three years
um or maybe it's two and then you can
divorce but the idea is they're saying
look if you can put up with someone you
don't want to marry
for two years you can stay here so green
card marriages
are a thing but that's not ours though
we got married because we love each
other
yes keep saying that loudly on the
podcast in case anyone is listening
so so uh after july
if you divorce me you won't lose your
green card um
i could apply in july for proof of
continued marriage we had to send the
immigrant services are love letters it
was crazy
like things to prove women like like all
the post-it notes i've ever left him and
like
every picture and all the letters that
he wrote me
hundreds of tiny torn out pieces of
notebook paper that were like slotted
into books and folded over that say in
tiny writing
i love you and we are definitely going
to get married and it is real
which was you know a real tough two
months of forgery to make sure that on
paper travel
right like i was looking when i applied
for my
0-1 visa which is the work visa i needed
before we were married to work in
america
as a comedian it was a 350-page document
that my lawyers put together and you
have to you know when i say my lawyers
had to pay people a lot of money to do
it like it
it's really expensive it's so expensive
to go to work in america
and it's worth it though greatest
country on the world right customs and
bureau protection
uh customers of border protection my
gosh i'm mixing up the fbi and
do you remember when we had our when we
had our um interview
let me finish off my sorry my 01 story
so my
lawyer said you really need to know the
first hundred pages of this
evidence you're submitting and most of
it was just articles saying he's a
comedian
reviews that said he's a good comedian
and letters from people within the
industry saying
he's very talented and the letters
because to get the visa it's it's called
the 01 the alien of extraordinary
ability
so you have to show that you are you
can't take jobs from americans because
they cannot possibly do what you can do
because no american can rap as well as
chris turner not in a british accent i
think that's the main thing i was like
no there's loads of great rappers but
how many of them
are up like this oh doff my cap and say
good day
um so i i sent in the application and
the
the letters that you get people to write
are so wonderful because you say the
lawyer explains them this needs to be
so over the top and so people who i
respect the big comedians were saying
chris turner is truly a
once-in-a-generational talent
the united states would be poorer
without him um
it's like american university
applications because um if you apply to
if you apply to like an english
university they understand that like
so-and-so is quite a good student is
actually very high praise but obviously
if you're applying to harvard and your
teacher writes so and so is quite a good
student harvard's going to be like
wow that is terrible i am never going to
let that person so they have to have
this special like briefing
for or they did for me um from you know
your teachers
who were writing your recommendations
for american schools so they could write
like a different set of recommendations
for them
right before you write this letter you
need to drink five cups of coffee
and just be effusive yes when i got to
the u.s embassy with my application
i was so nervous because i revised like
the week before like a test
all these entries so he could ask me
anything and i would say yeah so i get
to the
booth and there's this guy maybe in his
50s kind of bold shiny head
very american accent he looked like ed
harris the actor
and he he just says ah
comedian do you like carlin
as if this is some test like i'm going
to go yes it's my favorite
beverage um so i went oh yeah no he's
great i've watched all his specials i
really love his
poem that he starts you know one of his
latest specials with i mean he's dead
now
um and i said something along the lines
of you know oh it's such a shame such a
shame we've lost him
and he said yeah he's my favorite
comedian and then just
stamped my application gave it back to
me and i said oh so
if i hadn't if i had gone i think george
carlin is old-fashioned and hack
i would have not been allowed in to what
degree is this a
white privilege thing oh definitely
because like i do feel like it was so
hard for us to get our green card
and you are a middle-class white boy it
must be so impossible
if you have any level of oppression
or anything i would imagine so yes
definitely no it was it was a piece of
piss compared to
most other people um our interview
together oh yes so we had we had an
interview um
right where they basically kind of go
and you really are you really are
you love each other and we're like yes
and they're like do you secretly not
love each other and you're pretending
and you're like no and then and there
were several questions on this massive
list of questions which made me laugh
and it's a very polite woman that we had
she was great and
i mean this is another privilege i asked
my lawyer i said do you need to come to
the meeting with us
she says oh not for you guys and i was
like oh why she goes because you have a
strong case
but then everyone else in that office
was a person of color with their lawyer
with them
and obviously the lawyer charges for
that so they have to spend more money
just to have their lawyer there it's
[ __ ] up isn't it
um but so two of the questions that i
liked so one was
this was sort of depressing one was um
have you ever killed anyone
and i laughed and went who answers yes
to that and she was like
a lot of people and i was like oh she
had a person who
who said well in the war in my country
i threw a grenade into a trench where i
knew the enemy was
it exploded but i didn't go to check so
maybe maybe i have killed someone and so
i felt thoroughly carried
alice alice just laughed at these
questions to the point where
i think we you asked to leave the room
no i yeah i was so i was so tickled um
and there was another question where
after our friends had this response we
told them they're australian
and they had to leave the room what
because they laughed
yeah because they left the question the
the person interviewing them was like
i'm going to give you a minute to calm
down and then come back and answer these
questions seriously
i guess um it's probably not actually
cool to laugh at it because as
that woman told us like lots of people
have horrible answers to these questions
but um one of the questions was to chris
i mean they're all to chris uh one of
the questions was
um do you intend to marry a different
woman once you get here
and i was like well chris why don't you
tell them everyone's lips
before that interview i went through my
instagram
and i i deleted a picture um
i think i deleted it or maybe i'd
thought of deleting it maybe it's still
there
because after a show of mine at the
edinburgh festival my cousin
had come to the show and he said let's
grab a drink so we went to get a drink
he said
okay if my friend comes he saw the show
as well he thought it was really fun
and i said yeah and we go and sit down
and i say so what do you do he says oh
i'm a
member of the blah blah blah i said
what's that he goes that's the communist
party and
he was one of the leaders obviously
there is no leader
one of the leaders of the british
communist party it changed its name
because it merged in like the 80s with
another group
so i took a picture of me with him doing
like kind of you know a fist
up in the air and that was on my
instagram i think it is still there
because i thought
what are they going to do well are they
still that stuck up about communists
they are less upset about communists and
they than they once
were but again i mean all of these
stories i think
reveal uh how lucky we were
soup of privilege really because i mean
it
and i and i stress it was still really
difficult right i mean it was
[ __ ] expensive it took years yeah and
it you know it was such a hassle and yet
we had it at
the very easiest possible setting yeah
i mean i i can imagine it was amped up
because
it was just a champion yeah and like it
felt processing times took so much
longer you know when um indiana jones is
like escaping through doors and then
he'll like
you know the door shutting on him and
then he sneaks his hand and gets his hat
in just
that's what it felt like these loopholes
were closing around us as we went
through them
and it made me think why is he even
wearing that hat
you know if it's that important to you
leave it at home yeah
i don't know why we went on that tangent
really yeah
but uh hey you know i was gonna do a
joke about tanned
gents i don't think it sounds like that
was going to be a good joke not a very
good joke
um have you had a nice week alice win
i've had a great week actually yeah
mainly because of
the song that you showed me oh so alice
came up to me and she said i have a bone
to pick with you
and i it came out of nowhere i thought i
have not done anything wrong i mean
she's not supposed to know about my
intentions to marry another woman now
i'm in this country
and it was because i'd revealed to her
mother and her something that i i
thought
she was aware of which is a song
which is very close to my heart ever
since i discovered it maybe two years
ago now so chris went to
crossover yes i i went to i have a
friend who's a film director who
is from albania this is two years ago
this is not during the end times
and so we flew to albania
to to well i flew to albany to hang out
with him i was free for free
i actually didn't realize you'd gone to
i thought you went to north macedonia
yeah so i flew to albania
so this is i visited three capital
cities in one day
um kind of as a joke because he was like
hey let's just do it
by the way so it's albeit because i was
saying this to you earlier i have never
met an albanian who has not
invited me to come stay at their house
in albania and i've met quite a few
albanians i don't know why it just keeps
happening
and i my theory is this i suspect
albania is like drop dead gorgeously
beautiful but no one ever goes and so
all albanians
feel this like fervent patriotic
sort of desire to spread the news about
albania
so is it beautiful i only visited the
capital which is called tirana
and then the drive that we took was at
night so i didn't see
much of albania although albania kosovo
and macedonia are all very closely
situated
and so what i saw in macedonia still the
city center was was nice
but um so macedonia at the time was
called macedonia now macedonia is called
north macedonia are you sure about that
i think yeah it's got a different name
because greece got yeah so so the greece
the greeks get annoyed because
uh alexander the great is from macedonia
uh
the but the greek area called macedonia
macedonia the country did not exist so
the greeks were like can you stop
pretending that you have alexander the
great
and that there's a huge misinformation
campaign that was run by
the old kind of nationalist government
of macedonia they put up a statue of
alexander of massachusetts sneaky in
their central square in
skopje which is their their capital and
yeah they they have i mean the weirdest
museum i ever went to which was
the museum and you go to a lot of i do
well as an archaeologist anthropologist
i'm interested in museums and i go to
some weird ones but like the museum of
psychology or psychiatry
is run by scientologists it's mad it's
really mad don't use your real name when
you check in there otherwise they will
harass you all right but go on so this
was a weird museum was the museum of
macedonian history
and it's about how good the rebels who
established macedonia and fought the
cruel oppressors i don't know who they
were i think it was like ottomans
and they don't actually
have any macedonian history like it's
it's all a myth it's all myth-making
about this country
it's a nationalist ideology set by the
government who spent huge amounts of
money
on renovating the entire city center
with fake
greek architecture to kind of create
these ties to the past right to pretend
that they are where alexander the great
was from essentially yeah so
all the things in the museum are wax
works incredibly realistic like they've
hi
it's not like a shoddy wax work museum
it's they've hired really impressive
talented artists with all this money and
it was all corrupt and horrendous and
loads of backhanded kind of dealings
but it's just a freaky museum full of
wax works because they're creepy and
then they have rooms
where you walk in and there's nooses
from the ceiling with
wax work people who are dead in them
also on the way out they have
a room of world leaders and so it's wax
works of all like the most famous world
leaders
including hitler and stalin who were
just having a chat next to each other
um winston churchill's next him doing
his whole v for victory hitler's
saluting
it's very very strange the fun thing
that sticks out is they only do good wax
works for men
all the women are gen genuinely
shop mannequins that they put on even
like
this woman is the hero of macedonia she
saved so many people in the back and
it's no she is from a department store
and you've put a hat on
so okay all right we're getting off
track so we want to get back to the song
so we went to kosovo
kosovo we call it kosovo i think they
call it kosovo
we land him in albania my friend says we
just got this grant to make a film
let's we're going to drive back to
macedonia tonight have you ever been to
kosovo and said no he goes cool
well let's drive through kosovo so you
go to kosovo stop in pristina the
capital we'll have dinner then we'll go
on to macedonia
so we stopped in kosovo we went to this
restaurant
that was like the cool place everyone
went to he goes oh my friends are here
let's go sit down so we sit down at this
table throughout the whole meal
all these people keep coming up to one
of the guys at the table and just asking
for his autograph
and so i'm thinking oh wow i'm with like
this incredibly famous person
so i say oh who are you he's like oh
it's no big deal my friend says no he's
the biggest comedian in kosovo he hosts
like the morning show which is why
everyone coming up to him was a child
or an older woman i love the idea of
being really famous
in a small country and like this kind
it's kind of got a hannah montana appeal
to it
right because it's like you know you get
off the plane
in sri lanka and everyone's like oh my
god and then you go back to america
i think my sister had i used sri lanka
because my sister was briefly friends
with someone who was a pop star in sri
lanka
but he was just at yale with her
and so he would get off the you know
he'd get up jfk and he'd be a normal
person but when he went back to sri
lanka he was
incredibly famous i think that's a nice
way of being famous yeah
to be famous in a place my friend deliso
now quite well known in the uk because
he
came in the final of britain's got
talent but he's from malawi
and he can go and do shows in malawi and
sell loads of tickets partially because
his dad is a government minister and so
everyone's like oh he's going to say
some jokes about the government
but the problem is the government send
people to the shows to be like don't say
anything about the government like when
i did a show
in malaysia i had to
send them my script in advance even
though i freestyled a lot of it
because they censor it because you know
i'd say anything about the monarch in
malaysia well we're in spain uh yeah
and they didn't tell me in advance what
they were censoring for just they get
back when yeah thanks you didn't say
anything bad about the king
you could have asked me do you have any
bits about the malaysian king that
you're going to do
that show was at anywhere a sign on the
way and said rules number one do not
touch the performers
what an exciting venue you know it's
going to go down right and they only
have rules like that because
someone broke oh those performers got
touched yeah
okay okay so so we go to customs hanging
out with the most famous guy
yeah also at the same table with the
director
of kosovo's entry that year for the
oscars foreign film
contest which was a controversial thing
kosovo's majority muslim country
it was a film about a lesbian
relationship and so
people were getting death threats it was
very scary um
we then go to so you're like hanging out
with the
kosovo elite yeah oh yeah no i am the
liberal
the liberal elite of kosovo uh a very
right-wing
muslim majority country so at this meal
people kept asking me oh are you
american i said no i live there and they
go oh
we love america and i was like oh yeah
okay and they're like
do you not know that we love america
like do do people not know this about
our country and i
obviously you're like oh i'm really
sorry no one it's like when i'm in in
britain i say when i'm in america and i
say hi i'm from manchester and people go
manchester united i'm like yeah that's
all my city is known for
not the birthplace of the industrial
revolution well the cradle of industrial
revolution birthplace was in telford
um and so then they talked about they
talked about
a song they were like you know the song
though yeah and the song
i don't understand how this song is not
the most famous song in the world
it only has half a million views on
youtube which is a lot of views but it
it needs like i have videos of more
views than that i do not deserve that
my most popular video i i wish there was
a way of just transferring those views
to this song
and it's so sincere that's the beauty so
it's it's an it's an
albanian kosovan so kosovans are ethnic
albanians as far as i'm aware they speak
albanian
um and in the 90s kosovo was subject to
a campaign of ethnic cleansing
by the yugoslavians right but i mean
yugoslavia didn't exist then
it's to be honest with you we have not
done our due dates yeah we haven't done
our research on this
it's confusing very complicated history
in the 90s
in the eastern bloc countries and all
those kind of former
former kind of soviet states there
there was a lot of [ __ ] going down with
like bosnia
and serbia and croats and lots of ethnic
cleansing which is a nice way of saying
genocide
um and what happened was america and
britain let's not forget tony blair
got involved and we're like right let's
stop this and i remember as a child
being
eight or nine years old and being told
to make
shoe boxes it was called project
christmas child and at christmas which
is weird because
this is a muslim country at christmas we
would send
shoe boxes full of toys and candy to the
refugee children in kosovo
um so that they could find christ
through yeah
i remember things you weren't allowed to
put in you weren't allowed to put in
action men or anything to do with war
because they were seeing
people killed and slaughtered every day
so bill clinton stepped in and um
basically stopped the genocide kosovo
that like is to this day incredibly
grateful to america
america has a 75 approval rating as of
2018 in kosovo it's very impressive
since it is a song by a
by a singer um i sadly don't know his
name
call thank you usa and when you hear
it you'll think oh this can't be real
this is a joke there's someone trying to
go viral so i went and
my my brother was like i don't think
this is a real song and i was like let
me just go and google it and i found
this article on npr
and the first thing it is is it is an
interview with someone called
hissny rexa a cheerful 51 year old
farmer from western kosovo
who loves the united states
unconditionally because of america my
country exists
he declares so when donald trump was
elected america's president
i named my favorite wolf after him
you see trump wolf protects me
just like president trump will protect
kosovo he said
snuggling his wolf
and it's hard not to come off as elitist
pricks mocking a country where they have
pet wolves genuinely this song gives me
so much joy so what we'll have to do is
try and convey to you it is a song sung
entirely straight faced with a backdrop
of stock footage of tanks and american
armed forces protecting pristine
and the massive gold statue of bill
clinton
that kosovo has in its in its capital in
the same way
the sri lankan pop star is super famous
in sri lanka if bill clinton
ever wants to be praised he just needs
to go to prishtina
and people would lie down like why is he
seducing interns when he could go to
kosovo
and get a quickie off anyone in the
street so the song
itself is called thank you usa and we'll
have to try and approximate it
yeah so we get the lyrics up um yeah
let's do it yeah
we have been dealing with some very
trialing ah
so many just sound gremlins so now you
can see alice is coming through a gold
microphone
which is strangely not as good as the
one that's not gold isn't that confusing
precious metals
all the glitters is not gold yeah um so
we have we have the song yeah
the song that's worth it guys we're
gonna sing along we'll play it down here
hopefully we're not going to get any
copyright strikes
i don't think that arm and mythari will
be annoyed if we play it yeah
uh very respectfully singing along in
the accent
yeah and we got the lyrics as well right
yeah
see you can hear this vaguely in the
background
thank you usa you are
my best friend you are the peacekeeper
you are a legend thank
[Music]
[Music]
um this is just to give you a a flavor
of it yeah we'll describe this
okay so the video has tanks hillary
clinton get ready
oh no no no an extended guitar solo
america as the peacekeeper just think
about how much peace it keeps across the
world
yeah and let's go thank you usa
stopping general site helping small
crossover
stopping the wrong fight
[Music]
and then it carries on right there's
[Music]
okay here we go here we
we go this way we thank you
the song that we see memories will bring
in so many countries you are keeping
peace you
are the life saver you are the pain
released i love the verb there i don't
know if he actually sings it but it's in
the lyrics on the screen it says you are
the pain i just love the idea of
the us as just this like magical
peacekeeping country
oh yeah just going around stopping
genocide
stopping the wrong fight i mean in 1999
so many things happened but what was
more important than two men shaking
hands
and how lucky kosovo is to have a
premium for a second in the video yeah
tony blair
um but yeah how lucky they are to have
the name of their country around with
the name of their prime minister
so lucky so i think now it just just
repeats
the chorus five times the third one
drops down a bit kind of to build it up
again
yeah yeah it's it's very good
thank you usa we have to stop now you're
part of my
best player we've been self-indulgent
he has a very good goatee
i just love it and i want to unpack why
i love it because
uh obviously there's a little bit of
like mean-spirited
mocking of people speaking your language
not quite as well as you speak your
language which is a ridiculous thing to
mock anyone forever as if
i speak do they speak albanian i don't
speak albanian
so what the [ __ ] am i going on about are
you trying to write a hit song in
albanian now no but okay
i think what i love about it i think
what brings me so much joy
is just this sincere appreciation of
america i was thinking about the fact
that if the song was about
like canada or ireland it would be so
much less funny wouldn't scan either
thank you canada but it's just because
it's because like we are in a kind of
late stage american empire where we are
all very conscious of the ways in which
the us is not in fact the peacekeeper
that stops the genocides
that it is not the world's best friend
but i think it's nice to think of
to be reminded there was a simpler time
when america was
a worldwide genocide stopper a there's
no such thing as simpler times the past
was always as complicated as the present
someone went to history lessons i didn't
would you
anyway um so b
uh this is not the past they still love
america in kosovo yeah they do
um i mean
i i had such a lovely time there and not
just because on my first day in albania
while walking along late at night a
woman came up to me
a very pretty woman oh right i mean i'm
talking alice win level
came up to me and just started chatting
me up and my
friend and his brother were just
laughing and i didn't realize i was like
oh well
yeah i'm an attractive handsome man
maybe she's a big fan and she was just
like she just starts chatting to me and
then she goes
do you have um girlfriend back in
america she thought i was american
and i said i said i said um no
and she's like oh i have a wife and then
she walked away
so she wanted she wanted a green card
marriage so who am i to begrudge her
that
no exactly so this song has been
bringing me so much joy
all week i just love it i i love
i love the idea of america as my best
friend
the legend stopping genocide and this
morning
i woke up to the dulcet sounds of chris
making me a cup of tea and singing it in
the kitchen and i just thought it was
going to be
dad was in the kitchen as well and at no
point did he ask me what's that song
which is weird like that's just
willfully oblivious he was just like oh
it's probably just the normal song wheel
thing about america
yeah he's he's so pro america he was
like well of course you should be
walking around
this brit is lucky to be in my country
you better be saying thank you usa
damn right we stopped to genocide you
know what thank you usa in fairness they
did stop that genocide look if it
weren't for the usa then we wouldn't
have had that song
so um there's so many more stories i
could tell about my
albanian cosmic macedonian trip but
we've got to save some for
for the future yeah um yeah we should we
should the
this has been the longest intro and
really most of it's been done with bad
sound
but like i said the quality has been
good and i hope you enjoyed our singing
uh if only we could have recorded it
properly so i could have pro toolsed it
to
[ __ ] just like proper auto tune my my
dearest wish is that everyone who
listens to this podcast will go and
watch that song
and experience the true joy that is
thank you usa please do search thank you
usa
kosovo it will come up um there'll be a
link in the
comments as well tell me the news
tell you the news well in other news i
mean
really is anything ever going to top
that it's look we'll take let's tackle
the news this week at a clip let's just
go through it pretty fast because
one there's not been a lot of stuff
going on that i haven't already spoken
about because obviously the thing with
the news is it's not like
i tell you a news story and it stops
being a news story there is still a coup
in myanmar people are being killed there
is still covert everywhere
people are still dying that's all
carrying on
you know there's so much news news this
week um gwyneth paltrow has
covered and she's been suffering from
the effects of long covert
and she published on goop and in a video
her
strategies for dealing with long cocaine
so what were some of the
so there it's a no alcohol no meat
ketogenic diet
mixed with infrared saunas and
uh she's worked with some holistic
lifestyle therapists
and functional medical practitioners
at no point did she just say doctors and
she
said you know this is really gonna help
everyone who's suffering from long
covert like me
and nhs england that one of the heads of
the nhs said we're really sorry to hear
that miss paltrow is not well however
we recommend none of these things
uh i hope she's okay i really love
gwyneth paltrow because of
just the joy she she brings me uh
on a regular basis yes anyone who is
confident enough to believe their vagina
smells off patchouli
and to make a candle therefore they're
with so for those of you that don't know
and this was a thing all last year
gwyneth paltrow
sold a candle through goop her store
called my vagina that smelled
like of sandalwood and patchouli and
what i love about this
is that it's such a yeah you can't argue
with someone
who's like that's what my vagina smells
like because she'll just be like oh i'm
sorry is your vagina disgusting
yeah um so gwyneth paltrow we wish you a
healthy recovery
but i also think it's maybe follow
medical advice
rather than some guy who has dreadlocks
and went to goa once
let's move over to china we've got a
couple of china stories okay um
so number one there was a landmark court
ruling where
uh a couple divorced and the court
ordered the man
pay the woman 50 000 won for
house work she'd done over their
five-year marriage that's great
because on average in china the average
housewife does four hours of unpaid work
a day
which is um over four times as much work
as the man does
yeah the standard across all countries
is women do two times the unpaid
housework of men so china's really doing
quite bad about it in our household
how do you think oh yeah yeah yeah
comment below with how you think
the breakdown of housework in this house
goes i'm not bitter i need that green
card
chris is a modern man
i am a modern man yeah he cooks i am the
third model of a modern major man
gilbert sullivan in it i can't do that
song just i'm not going to i'm going yes
i'm going to request that you don't
uh okay so that's that's an interesting
ruling i think that's
good right 50 000 yuan for five years
work is about
seven seven thousand dollars i think so
okay um
yeah seven thousand dollars so nothing
and people have commented you can't even
hire a nanny for one year for fifty
thousand dollars
but it's uh it's a big deal yeah it's
because it's kind of
untangible assets and so when it comes
to divorces people in china it's very
rare to have a prenup
um so people don't have you know this
way to split things such as property
houses
children uh you know they can't split
unpaid work and child care in the same
way
uh yeah good on her yeah i approve of
that because you know for
other people the woman ends up doing a
lot of work in the household i can't
imagine what that's like but i
i'm sure it's dreadful second new story
out of china
i told you about this earlier this week
uh to do with covid
and us diplomats and ambassadors and
people who work in the u.s embassy
in china one of the ways they've been
testing for covid because apparently
it's more accurate than just a nasal
swab
is a swab at the other end of your body
they
they swab your bum and apparently it can
test for lingering covid and usually
it's only done for people in quarantine
or people who are recovering however
many u.s ambassadors and diplomats have
said that they have been
subjected to because that's the phrase
you use isn't it if it's to do with your
bum you're subjected to it yes
subjected to anal swapping to test for
covid which makes me think of your
friend
who once told us that horrible story
about how he made a bomb joke
in a plane once in an airport once and
is now
on a list where every single time he
flies
he has to have an anal check
yeah an anal cavity search and we were
like that's terrible and he was like you
get used to it
i mean you have to yeah you have to so
yeah the chinese government has said oh
this this didn't happen
but the diplomats have said no beijing
responded to us and said oh that was an
error
but really i think it's just china going
oh you think we started this virus oh
all this [ __ ] you're saying about us
fine uh let's swab your ass you
[ __ ] which
is a great way of getting back yeah it's
so petty it reminds me of
um i think i think chris jeff came to
america
towards the end of the cold war and all
he wanted
all he wanted this story wreaked my
heart was to go to disney world or
disneyland he didn't really
just he wanted to go to disneyland he
just really wanted to they want to meet
the mickey mouse he really wanted to
meet mickey mouse
but i want to see donald doug to be dix
the american government was like it's
too dangerous whereas actually they're
just like
no you don't get any fun chris that's
exactly what it was and it breaks my
heart because it means christoph never
went he never went to disneyland
and christian quite a decent dude right
so sad
sad times very sad uh american fallen
foreign policy american foreign policy
news american foreign policy
news they've released the report on the
killing of
journalist and u.s citizen resident
jamal khashoggi
uh who was chopped up in the turkish
embassy i don't know anything about this
okay cool that was about two years ago
well um jamal khashoggi was distant
wrote stuff about saudi arabia so is he
it was theorized that
is he a saudi arabian yes okay saudi um
the theory was that the crown prince
mohammed bin salman
mbs as they call him had a part in
ordering his murder
and during trump's administration
because they sell arms to the saudis and
want to keep them on side
trump's like let's not say that and
biden's come in and
issued the report from the cia that says
no he
he ordered this he said and so there's
tension between the countries oh no
what's saudi arabia going to do is it
going to buy all its weapons from russia
and china now
maybe but uh also america has not gone
far enough it hasn't really sanctioned
him it's just said yeah he did this
okay so let me just let me just clarify
so several years ago probably the crown
prince of saudi arabia
had a dissident journalist chopped up
which is horrible
and trump was like that's fine and biden
is like
not so fine yeah and now we're like what
a typical liberal
typical left winger saying that chopping
people up is wrong
you have a very strong left-wing bias
when it comes to chop people up i think
there's one position that people should
always fall on and i think
that should be the left-wing side which
is we should say no to chopping up
people
so that's so false because there have
been plenty of leveling regimes that
chop people up
i will point your way to the the terror
of 1793 in france which was incredibly
[ __ ] left-wing i wouldn't say that
guillotining someone is chopping someone
up i'd say
chopping a part off you are splitting
hairs um well that's what
they do when as a left-winger i say that
is wrong
this happened on the day of recording
our last show daft punk they've broken
up
they're not a group anymore were they
still a group yeah deaf punk was still a
group i mean they haven't really done a
song until
since random access memories was their
last one oh
you're friends no get lucky no wait wait
wait wait wait
that's justice oh
all french electro dance groups are the
same
justice look i don't read the news and
i'll be honest i don't listen to music
that's fine well daft punk did harder
better faster stronger
around the world around the world
um they did get lucky i remember get
lucky
uh lose yourself to dance that was from
that same album with the same people
yeah it's a lot of people are very sad
so it's two it's two
french robots two french robot men yeah
and they were
they're not dating no they're just
working together
is that your assumption with every
closed male friendship uh yes
okay i just wanted you said they broke
up
well as a band alice every time a band
breaks up are you like oh and all the
romantic relationships that
they are involved with yes that's why
it's so sad about the beatles
you very silly wife more music news you
don't listen to music you know who lady
gaga is i know who she is yes
lady gaga she got her dogs kidnapped i
actually know about this they shot her
[ __ ]
they did shoot her dog her dog is okay
and then they kidnapped her dogs and
she's kidnapped two of the dogs but not
the one that has the instagram account
that one escaped
so they they really missed out on the
most famous stuff okay but so she
the she's given a prize for if anyone
what's it what would that be she gave
half a million rewards right i think and
they've been returned they were turned
by a woman to a police station jeez
by the way just so people i can continue
to wonder at how much news i pick up by
osmosis
someone texted me this week and was like
i woke up first thing i knew
text on my phone lady gaga's dog water
walker's been shot and i was like
thank you keeping me up to date dog
walkers in la
and this is this happened in l.a it
happened actually on a road not too far
from where
we lived in la um i mean we you know we
live near two of the main shootings in
la lady gaga's dog walker
and where christopher wallace aka the
notorious b.i.g
was murdered i'm sorry the notorious
big's real name is christopher wallace
yes
really do you not think it's like oh
congratulations it's a baby boy oh
lovely i'm going to call him biggie
smalls
i do think biggie small seems like a
reasonable name biggie the baby biggie
smalls i think that's adorable
okay um christopher wallace isn't that
the guy who does the debates
between the presidents for like biden
and trump those debates
wasn't there a guy who's the guy who
like moderated the debates between biden
and trump
yes maybe christopher wallace is the
journalist who did anchor one of the
things
okay christopher george la torre wallace
i'm not i'm not mad i do know the names
of
the most famous rappers i just think
that that's sort of
a charming little link so biggie smalls
has the same name or had the same name
as
the fox he was actually named after the
fox news anchor christopher wallace yeah
his mum was like oh that's a nice
person's name
okay um right yeah so so i hope that
the dog walker is all right yeah
apparently the dog walker is all right
lady gaga has the dogs back by the way
how [ __ ] violating
to have your dog walk a shot and your
dog's taken yeah and how violating to be
shot so what i was saying about dog
walkers in la is whenever you saw them
it was always
pretty pretty crazy the number of dogs
like
ten dogs on the leash yeah they i mean
they'd be pulled along it's an
irresponsible number of dogs
oh no definitely i mean it looks like
they're going to like pull
you know shackleton to the south pole
dogs they have how do we know that the
people who took the dogs
it wasn't a targeted thing they just
thought that man has too many dogs we
need to
help out let's take a couple of them
let's shoot one of them oh no we missed
i like to think that lady gaga would pay
her doug walker enough that he wouldn't
have to or she would not have to
uh have 10 dogs in her lead being a big
scandal
up in canada over the texture of their
butter
lots of canadians have noticed that the
butter in canada
is not as spreadable at room temperature
as it used to be
and someone did a deep dive and they
figured out this is because during the
pandemic
baking has gone up so there's a higher
demand for butter yeah a 12
increase and so the canadian dairy
farmers
were at a loss what to do they need to
produce more milk so what they did was
they started adding
palm oil to their cattle feed palm oil
is always
it's always bad isn't it yeah you never
hear a story about like and then palm
oil
saved the day nestle you know who are a
bad company anyway because we don't know
why
they they got uh mothers in
several african countries hooked on a
baby formula
so the problem is you they they would
give these mothers free baby formula
right um but only a limited supply so
the mothers would be like okay great
this is more
so they'd stop breastfeeding and
therefore stop lactating
and then um then they have to start
paying really high prices to continue
it's i mean it is like a like a drug
dealer yeah i remember someone told me
this story and then an anthropologist
was explaining how
in many um areas people would not use
the baby formula because it had a
picture of
a a white baby on the front but b
like in many of these countries because
illiteracy is a problem
what a thing is is always on the
container so they thought it was
powdered baby so they thought it was
baby they thought what are these heathen
europeans doing eating
these babies um yeah which also reminds
me of the story of the i think this is
definitely apocryphal
about um like the world health
organization or some health
charity air-dropping
anti-diarrhea medication because
diarrhea kills
so many people because it dehydrates you
air-dropping this diarrhea medication
over an area that was having like a real
problem but it was a country
that spoke arabic and so with it they
included a little cartoon strip which
was you know frame one
someone having diarrhea frame two
them taking this medicine frame three
them looking happy
however with arabic you read right to
left so what they saw was
you're feeling happy take this pill you
will [ __ ] profusely
i don't think that can ever have
happened that seems like a dumb thing
that someone would have done
so they've been putting palm oil in the
butter and now that's just they add palm
oil to the cow feed
to make the cows produce more milk which
is the thing that's happened for a long
time but they've been doing it more
and so therefore the butter now is
theorized they've still got to
investigate
has a higher palm oil content and palm
oil is bad for you is that right palm
oil is from
rain forests and so to get it you have
to kill
orangutan habitats or something right
well yeah no it's not
it's not ethically so nestle stop doing
it you can ethically source palm oil
i believe the big problem with palm oil
is
it's the main ingredient in nutella and
nutella
already bad because it's made from
hazelnuts taken with child labor which
is
and when they asked ferrero the company
that make nutella
because they use i think 70 percent no
what maybe it was one quarter or one
third of the world's hazelnuts plant
maybe more but that all comes from
turkey
and it's using child migrant labor and
the children of refugees
and they said hey can you like
sustainably source this can you track it
and make sure it's not children
and the ceo just said i mean we can try
but there's no way we could ever be sure
the fact that nutella is made with
child labor really proves the oscar
wilde quotation about
there being sorrow under everything yeah
yeah well that's and you mix it with
palm oil so they said they tried making
it without palm oil and it didn't have
the same glossy consistency and texture
that nutella fans
love so you know if you like nutella you
are killing orangutans
listen we tried having gladiator fights
without the gladiators dying at the end
and
they just didn't have the same violent
bloody texture that the gladiator finds
i don't want to see a trapeze artist
over a safety net
anyway okay yeah so the the canadian
dairy industry said look we're going to
stop adding all this palm oil while we
get to the bottom of this
because we want to reinstate the faith
in canadian dairy
i hope any canadians listening i hope
your butt is spreadable
i mean the thing is room temperature in
canada must be it must be harder to get
your butter at spreadable temperature
i don't know if all of canada is the
same cold temperature
no i'm pretty sure it's a mono climate
um okay
so i feel as if this can't be all the
news
that is all the news that can't be so
the the other well you have got some
more news you got breaking news
oh yes so this is to do with i guess one
of the big events this week was cpac
which is the conservative political
action conference
uh down in florida this is the thing
where they were like this is
uncancelable oh yeah so america
uncancelled is there is there slogan
and then they can't cancel he was found
to have reprehensible views which
you know for for a conservative
conference to cancel you for
representable views maybe he was like
i believe that no one should ever be
chopped up ever um
i've got that wrong i got [ __ ] it was
going to be a good joke i got to run
around
um i'm not even going to edit that out
and let you know that sometimes guys i'm
flawed
[Laughter]
just i hope you are flawed by my lyrical
wordplay
i know i am i am okay so someone was
cancelled in
cpac what else happened well there's
lots of stuff
their stage is in the layout of some
rune
that was worn on hitler's collar um
there i don't i don't think that i think
that is a coincidence
awesome photoshop manipulation hey maybe
it's fake news oh by the way last week
we said that uh texas was
taxes bigger than france it's not it's
like 1.3 times bigger i said it was such
confidence that i hope that the thing
you take away
from these uh podcasts is not any other
fact but just the idea of
spouting falsities with confidence if
you say anything in a british accent
this is a whole bit of mine i say you
know i convinced a man in san diego
maple syrup is just honey that's made by
canadian bees
you know you just say it in a british
accent they're like okay i i don't i
think that's an
obnoxiously smug sentiment and i don't
like it when british people say that
why do the yankees always win because
the opponents can't take the eyes off
the stripes
two mouse mice fell in a vat of cream it
is i think the movie that
it's my desert island movie catch me if
you can i can watch it over and over and
over and over and over again and i don't
get bored of it it really is fantastic
brilliant all right go back on to what
we were saying cpac cpac
um so the breaking news was that trump
uh
was meant to speak today about an hour
before we started recording this
and by the time we started recording he
still hadn't shown up and the reports
were he hadn't even left his house
yet well he's busy you know yeah he's
busy he's very busy
um so he's probably giving a speech
right now
i don't know what he's saying i imagine
it's the same speech he's given for the
last five years about
the the vote being started well you know
that
oh biden's bad mexico is bad
um there was a giant gold statue of
trump at cpac
and is it actually like made of gold no
it's
sprayed in gold i missed the days when
rich people
just made things out of like that's a
real gold microphone you're talking
through
it's not a real gun that is that's
probably gold-plated that's from the rap
god tour
when i asked my my business manager is
is it got like tax deductible to get a
gold microphone if it's for the show
they said yeah i was like brilliant i'm
getting a gold microphone
does it improve the sound no um but it's
gold
i remember reading somewhere that jay-z
had a solid gold
toilet or a rocking horse maybe it was
both and i just thought well saddam
hussein had a gold toilet
i'm getting it so sadami's only gold
color and jay-z had jay-z's birth name
actually was saddam hussein so it's easy
to confuse
and uh i just approve of that i think
you know if you're gonna be
do you remember what happened at um
blenheim blenheim palace in oxford
go on so there's an italian artist who
i think he's most famous for having this
sculpture which is
the pope kneeling in prayer being hit
by an asteroid i'm sorry wait as in
he's like a very so his sculpture is of
a statue being hit by an asteroid
his sculpture is the pope being hit by
an asteroid
so he made a sculpture of a functioning
gold toilet solid gold and it was i
believe it was entitled america
so that was the joke there oh look at me
i do honestly and for a retrospective
of his career in blenheim palace which
is winston churchill's childhood home
yeah it's in oxford they installed it
and you could get a ticket
to go and use the gold toilet and
someone asked the
curator aren't you worried about this
solid gold toilet like that's worth five
million pounds and the curator says well
he's going to steal a toilet
within 24 hours of that exhibition
opening somebody stole the toilet
flooded the palace because it was
plumbed in yeah
and that toilet has never been found
that just got melted straight down
just boom that's like the next oceans
maybe isn't it
there was this gold statue of trump that
everyone was taking photos with
just turned out that was made in mexico
so that's fun
and the the the main thing at cpac
everyone kept bringing up
is that people are trying to um
cancel mr potato head that's what
they've been saying
because hasbro has brought mattel who
make mr potato head
just published a press release saying
hey we're rebranding the line the line's
called potato head
because we've got mr potato and mr
potato head and baby potato head
and every single person speaking at this
conference she's just like
keep talking while i [ __ ] off oh because
the cat wants to come in
hello yeah look at this
apologies listeners viewers though cat
time
all right so um potato head is being
cancelled because
well so yeah because they published this
thing saying hey look on the packaging
it's now going to say
potato head at the top and then the
bottom the name of the character
all these conservatives said they're
trying to
re-gender mr potato head now it's
his pronouns are they oh it's like
potatoes don't have gender you [ __ ]
potatoes
how can you get pissed how can you get
so
irate and riled up one at something that
hasn't happened because they're not
renaming him
he's still called mr potat they've
renamed the brand because it reminds me
of um when we
first got colonel and i went on a google
rampage and i found this yahoo answers
question that made me so happy it was um
someone who was like
hey uh i just found out that my cat is
actually a boy cat
but i thought it was a girl cat and so
i've been referring to him as she
for a month or two will my cat be okay
uh towards the answer is no okay your
cat is gay now
totally gay so that's all the news we're
now on to where alice is going to tell
us
what she's learnt this week all the
while accompanied by a gentle purr
of a a cat in her lap so alice i didn't
feel like i read anything um
that easy to tell so i thought i might
just talk a little bit about richard
kiplink
um because you know he's famous and
people that's a dumb name
oh okay rudyard rudyard is the lake in
staffordshire where his parents fell in
love
oh that's quite nice what were their
names windermere and coniston
no uh his names were two very famous
british lakes there for anyone who
didn't get that
coruscating bit of wit his mother was
one of four sisters who were all
um quite they all married fashionable
people so her
um his his aunt married edward byrne
jones the pre-raphaelite painter oh yeah
uh his aunt was called aunt alice and he
loved her and that's like my name
um so rudyard kipling uh kipling is
kibbling's an interesting character
right because um
he was the poet of empire um so
like recently the um you know there was
the new jungle book that came out oh
you're quite all right colonel whitachen
can you [ __ ]
leave for those of you that can't see
full on tail in her face
he's just caressing you gently with his
fluffy tail can you sit down at least
i think he's trying to leave i think
he's trying to figure out ever leave me
why why me so his legacy
is really really um complicated so for
instance a couple of years ago
manchester university put up um his one
of his most famous poems sorry mentioned
so that's manchester united
that uh poem called if and they wrote it
on the walls
and the students were like we we don't
want this like
jingoistic imperialist to have space on
our walls right jingoistic is a very
good word
jingoism can you can you kind of define
that um
as far as i can tell it's just like uh
imperialistic racism it's okay
it's the belief that we need to go and
like conquer the other peoples
uh i think that's not a great definition
but that's the gist yeah
if you need jingoism to find in a sound
it's this
that's i think what it is absolutely uh
and so yeah
the the students at the university um
probably fair enough we're like look we
don't we don't want that up on our walls
uh
it feels offensive to like for instance
any indian
students at the university so they put
up they painted over it and put up
a poem by maya angelou and so then this
brought in this huge discourse like to
what extent should we even
read kipling anymore right kipling wrote
the jungle book that's his most famous
piece he also wrote the um the just so
stories uh he wrote
if he wrote ganja din he wrote kim um
he wrote a ton of stuff um
and he's he's a very good writer that's
the awkward thing right um
his way with words is enchanting um
and i think when i was reading about him
the thing i
kind of clicked with most was not really
any of the modern articles because i
found that the modern articles um
like there's one it was on gizmodo it
was
called reminder kipling is
um a racist [ __ ] and
the jungle book is imperialist garbage
and
the article actually was more nuanced
than that title would suggest so that's
one side of the story and then there's
other articles where it's people
um and it is generally white dudes being
like
actually kipling's great by the way uh
and so what i
liked was um george orwell wrote an
essay in 1942
about kipling whenever we look at
history we're looking at history from
the the lens of our of our
uh politics right um and that's what's
so interesting about this essay is that
george orwell is writing in the middle
of world war ii and
it is so just like mired in his fears of
fascism
and it's it's a really interesting essay
because it tells you so much about
kipling but it also tells you so much
about orwell and and
england during the war britain during
the war um but
what he says is so he's writing a
response to
a a version of kipling's verses that had
just come out and that had been edited
by t.s eliot the famous poet ts eliot
proof rock and the wasteland and imagine
having your name
be an anagram of toilets
that's so bad is it there's not an o in
there oh there is no in there
she's dyslexic so anyway um so ts eliot
massive anti-semite so he was totally
fine was he yeah yeah oh pals
every pound was ezra pound also bad oh
yeah
there's a cocktail bar in perth in
western australia called ezra pound
which is really cool
and i did not until now realize that
uh yeah the design scheme they go with
pretty anti-semitic as well so
anyway so so what george orwell starts
with saying is he goes look
the first thing you have to say about
kipling is that he is morally repugnant
and you have to start by saying that and
you can you can go
on from there and say yet i like his
work
but you you cannot try and disguise that
or excuse it right i mean
kipling is the man who coined the phrase
the white man's burden
he was like which explain that the white
man's burden is a poem that he wrote
the complicated politics is to do with
america and the philippines but uh
basically the idea is isn't it hard to
be white because
of the burden you carry of having to
share civilization
with the non-white parts of the world
and
this is something orwell unpacks as he
says the the
the reason for um kipling's sincere
belief
in empire as a force for good is that he
didn't see empire as an economic
prospect
he didn't understand that empire is not
just
british people going to india and
building trains empire is british people
going to india and building
trains so that they can take india's
resources away
faster right it's it's an economic
prospect
and kipling kind of wasn't part of the
elite enough to understand that
um and so he really just thought of
empire as this
force for good um and i find kipling a
sort of
um sad figure in
a lot of ways um because of what
happened with his son
so he you know he really passionately
believed in the party line
and and what's interesting about kipling
is that um you know he wasn't critically
popular because he was a commercial
success yes
but because what orwell says is he he
voiced
unpopular opinions in populist ways
because even in like the 1890s 18 you
know
early 1900s um you know educated people
were like hang on i think maybe this
empire thing is actually damaging
india or whatever right it's everyone
wasn't blindly oblivious to the evils of
empire they were they
they could see and they had problems
it's like when people
say oh you know it was a different time
when we had slavery and
you're like no john adams was
anti-slavery they were all the people
who said it was a bad thing
right here were all the religious
leaders who said hey we shouldn't be
enslaving people right
so no it's a similar thing and so um
yeah kipling
put unpopular views of empire into
populist
terms uh and orwell actually defines
kipling as writing what he calls good
bad poetry and good bad poetry is
poetry that expresses something a
universal feeling that we're all going
to have
in in simple terms that are easy to
remember
but kipling really did believe in all of
this very sincerely
um and you know he he spent some time in
india so he um he was born
in india i believe um and lived there
until he was five and then
quite traumatically was sent to england
when he was five years old
to go live in a boarding house with a
family that were very unkind to him and
no one noticed that they were
mistreating him until he was 12 when his
dear aunt alice who was married to
edward burne jones uh rescued him and
she said to him she was like why didn't
you tell me that they were treating you
badly
and he said as an adult he realized it's
because children
always believe they deserve however
they're treated and it doesn't occur to
children
that if they're being treated badly it's
because they it might be
wrong right they just think well i guess
this is how i should be treated
um which is sad anyway uh and then he
went back to india for a little while
um when he was like 16 or 17 he he lived
um in actually i guess now it's
modern-day pakistan
um but not that much time in india
considering how much of his work
is set there really i think it was just
a very formational
point zero to five
sixteen to twenty one and also if you
lived there everything was nice and then
you moved away and suddenly it becomes
horrible
yes i don't want to excuse his um really
quite gross opinions i mean you can't
you you can't read the white man's
burden the poem and not think he's a
massive old racist
the other thing that's really sad about
him um
yeah ori his son so um
i find kipling's works really
interesting because if you
if you're a boy born in 1896
you will grow up reading kipling stories
and kipling stories
are all about how like the highest
masculine ideal
is bravery stoicism and obedience
so if you're born in 1896 you're turning
18 i believe in
1914 and so you turn
18 in 1914 britain goes to war with
germany and
you sign up to go fight because that's
the brave stoic obedient thing to do
and that's the heroic ideal that you
have we should we should just
talk about how people listening might
think oh if there was a war i wouldn't
fight
but if you think of yourself at the time
in that context
i think it was pretty impossible if you
were if you were
to not do it you were outcasted you were
shunned
yeah it was so people would come up to
you and give you a white feather a white
feather
girls young girls would come up to you
and give you a white feather
and if people saw that happening they
would mock you they were you know
like you were pretty much forced to go
and fight and if you were like 16 and
not old enough
people would still expect you to do it
and the army recruiting officers would
happily take you even though you weren't
old but you hear stories
you hear stories of um you know like a
you know a 17 year old boy going to the
enlistment office and
they say how old are you and he says i'm
17 and they'd say go take a walk around
the block and come back when you're 18.
um so especially at the beginning of the
war you know it was really bad and
kipling's own son john turned 18 in 1915
and he was just desperate to go fight
and he had really bad eyesight he tried
to enlist twice and he um
they wouldn't let him they wouldn't pass
him for action because he
like couldn't see well and so i think i
would have escaped then
yeah yeah probably because you have a
terrible eye yeah um
amazing but kipling uh
pulled some strings because he was like
i think he you know he won the nobel
prize
for literature and uh i did not know
yeah he was the first english
speaker to win the nobel prize um i mean
the nobel prize was very new
and he also was poe was he poet laurie
or was he offered poet laureate i think
he was
whatever i'm going to move on to the
poetry thing i can't remember um
point is he pulled some screen strings
and so
his son john um was allowed to enlist
and his son went straight off to battle
of luz in 1915.
um the battle of lose is a very ominous
name it was i'd call it the battle of
wind
and this is such a terrible terrible
battle i mean
we all know about verdun we all know
about the psalm yes we all know about
verdun
but um the battle of luz is appalling i
mean
it's just these men are lined up in
blocks like they're on a parade ground
and they haven't been assigned
metal helmets yet they're wearing cloth
caps and they just
walk in blocks into machine gun fire and
all of them are killed right i mean
they're just mowed down
and so the last time anyone saw
kipling's son john
18 year old son john he was stumbling
blindly forward with what looked like a
facial injury and they didn't find his
body
until 1992 and um
kippling wrote a poem the next year uh
i think it was called epigraphs of war
epigrams of war and it has this
um line in it um
how does it go when they ask
why they died tell them because their
fathers lied something like that
shivers me yeah it's horrible we should
really put a contact warning on this
podcast that this podcast is very sad
look we've really taken on a roller
coaster you know we painted this man as
this horrendous imperialist racist pig
but now you feel sympathy for him
i think one of my main beliefs is that
you can feel sympathy for monsters
because otherwise
how would you love me it's too easy to
believe that you yourself cannot do
anything monstrous
um kipling interesting guy i don't know
um
should we learn him should we not learn
him i think if you're going to read if
by kipling very good poem you should
probably also read
if i rise by maya angelou very good poem
similar themes
what does kenneth wishes think colonel
whitachen's
is trying to drop drop a beat sternly
purring yeah well thank you so much
telling us about
roger kipling um yeah much more than
just someone who makes cakes
only a joke that people who listen in
the uk will get as always it's the end
of the show which means it's time for
me to do a freestyle rap about the
events of the week as suggested by my
wife
based on what we've talked about i have
a beat i have a lot of cat fur
in my mouth alice you're not gonna be
able to hear the beats it's gonna be
kind of awkward but just
imagine that it is hot stuff um
what okay you got it you're ready uh
yeah drop that b watch it
gender neutral mr potato head great
conservatives say oh no
where's the gender of potato it be going
there's no need to offend you
it's all a lie they ain't changing the
gender why
it can be improved they're mr potato
head he's just an amorphous tuber
if you put a dress on and he starts to
flirt that's fine mr potato head can
wear a skirt little baby one too
they say it's not good why you get
offended by the gender of a spud
what we got now golden trump statue okay
little gold trump
and they hope it stays in the white
house but it won't happen we hold you go
over turn election when the statue sold
gold is the problem they made it
south of the border that's a type of
people that trump said was out of order
got a cat sat
here at my feet just looking while i'm
rapping yeah if i were to meet bill
clinton when i was in pristina everybody
would bow down his shoes would be
cleaner than they'd ever been before
cause they're licking them stopping all
the genocide clinton is kicking them out
the serbs and the bosnians saying go
away
thank you thank you usa
even if it's not reserved if you're
taking all the pooches out and [ __ ]
by the curb then careful
doing all of that job if you're doing it
for lady gaga
i'll get shot by a random guy trying dog
nap
got a cat on my lap when i drop raps
he's trying to
escape yo kiss and make up not
relationship but somehow they break up
you're confused
why is it not a boy and a girl it's a
boy and a boy they do
around the world making those dance
tunes
all men and women love that with the edm
i'll be saying oh daft punk drop another
she's a rover of her mind always making
things up and she be lying
if you like vagina candles then you're
crying with glee because it smells
just like patchouli not vaguely salty
and gooey what a horrible
rhyme that i spit infrared saunas for
the aftercare
if you're over in china let me discuss
you gotta pay your
lady if it busts open relationships
like 50 thou cause she doing all the
work every day in the house
polish surfaces she deserves it fool
gotta get a prenup if you
wanna get the rules set straight can't
avoid you get yourself a lawyer
if if you're in china i'll avoid the
anal swab i thought i was predicting i
thought she'd say anal swaps the chinese
are sticking but no that not be the word
that she
uh she's working hard with the toil in
the palm oil butter you make sure that
the cows
increase the output canadians they're
like oh no
good eh i like maple syrup to be sticky
and buttered to be soft at room
temperature this icky it's too
icy it's staying too solid look at all
the palm oil the cows have swallowed
any more we want to do one more thing oh
talk about rajyad kipling the battle of
blues was where his son died
he was so upset yeah and his bum cried
and also him
still we won't take the piss he wrote
the white man's burden but also if
very complicated as an individual so
do your studies before you answer those
riddles
yeah there we go look at that
i worry that us talking so much about
kipling being complicated makes it sound
like we're making excuses for him
uh we're not roger kiplin massive racist
dick let me say that there we go
cool i'm i'm in the clear okay in the
clear look at that
um well thank you very much alice wynn
thank you for giving your suggestions
uh and thank you you for listening for
watching however you choose to imbibe
our content something you invite
brilliant i think
this is an imbibable piece of content
you can
imbibe it um if you want to find out
more about us
alice wynn where you at i'm on instagram
at let's then eat books with underscores
instead of spaces
i'm also on instagram chris turner
comedy um
share the podcast with your friends
leave a review on the apple podcast app
tell people hey do you want to know
what's going on in the world you've got
to listen
to this boy and this girl um it rhymes
what that's my job i make up rhymes
don't disparage me
your job is to teach us well i didn't
want to say that
no i have to keep on a good side for
just five more months before i can get
that sweet sweet unconditional green
card
until then thank you so much for
listening from me chris turner from her
alice win
[Music]
goodbye